President Obama held a news conference
today to share his take on the midterm
election results yeah and you can tell
the president wasn't taking it well
because he addressed the White House
press corps from inside a pillow fort
come on out mr. president not gonna do
it
yes how he talks now he had he had footy
pajamas on he had footie pajamas he
bummed out but history was made for the
first time ever a black Republican woman
has been elected to Congress yeah
President Obama gave her a
congratulatory call and told her you're
all set this country never turns against
the first black anything yesterday
Washington DC voted to legalize
recreational marijuana Washington high
school Washington DC yeah
President Obama said and after these
midterms thank God he's driving around
the neighborhood right now the Country
Music Awards took place tonight you
probably all watched yeah Country Music
Awards so for the second night in a row
the big winners were all white guys in
cowboy hats
[Applause]
I like that it really alone that was
pointed yeah
I didn't laugh but yeah see what he's
doing enough okay
Clay Aiken in the news former American
Idol star Clay Aiken lost his election
for Congress yeah apparently his
supporters thought they could vote by
texting Ryan Seacrest
this picture ryan seacrest all night
what no it's blowing up yeah in Vermont
the governor's race is so close the
Vermont legislature may have to choose
between the two candidates yeah so we
won't know until next week if the winner
is Ben or Jerry those are the only two
people in Vermont any of us know yes we
have a deep understanding of Vermont
politics yeah you bet I do
yeah there is other news out there
celebrity news Oprah released her list
of favorite things of 2014 and one of
them is a book that she wrote yes that's
true the book is called I'm Oprah and
you'll like what I say you'll like and
you'll like it now in our eyes burst
into flame well some sad news for some
of you ladies Benedict Cumberbatch has
gotten engaged yeah he is fiancee are
registered at cumber bed cumber bath and
cumber beyond
[Applause]
you